cool so welcome everyone good morning
for those who wake up if you didn't wake
up I will try to wake you up with
terraform I don't know how it works but
we'll try
so thanks ok
my name is Anton by Bianca and quite
recently I was recognized as there's
community here of because I do pretty
many different activities related to
terraform and AWS so AWS decided to
award me so I also organized a bunch of
different user groups here in Norway and
in Oslo Hoshi Corp user groups AWS user
groups DevOps Norway and also conference
devops days Oslo but for the last four
years I've been spending pretty much
daily at some point enormous amount of
time to contribute to different
terraform a SS projects some of them
listed here and some of them I will be
covering in more details in particular
you can always ask me on Twitter
LinkedIn or email if you have any
questions about the talk or about
terraform or AWS
I really like to answer them so what I
do obviously it's a terraform is hot
everybody wants to use it so I write a
lot of open source projects which turn
out to be paying me nothing ok so that's
why I provide consultant workshops
mentorship and more traditional set of
services because it's pretty hard to get
rich from just write an open source code
which actually some of you room in this
room actually using so I'm glad for that
for to begin with in about 2015 I
started write in different terraform AWS
modules figure out what is it how to use
them and then I published many of them
and then they become actually quite
popular most of them are verified by
Hoshi Corp and they get stamped and
actually more than four millions of
downloads for the last two years so a
lot of people need to use them and use
them if they want to build in
structure on AWS like if you need to
setup VPC on auto scaling group it's
very hard to be really unique and you
just have to use something existing like
in general programming language we've
been using the live choice right so
that's that's what terraform a SS
modules another product which I'm
affiliated with as cloud craft it is the
best way to draw a diverse diagrams for
your project where you can visualize all
of your infrastructure in the browser
and you can connect them you can specify
different properties you can actually
import live AWS infrastructure you can
see budget you can embed it into your
confluence wiki you can export this
image and many many different things but
you may think like why cloud crafts ok
cloud craft is probably not developer
friendly because it's all in the browser
and I'm here to emphasize the value of
infrastructure as code using terraform
ok so infrastructure as code makes
devops possible because only if we write
something as a code then we can actually
treat it similar as we do with
application code we always know what has
changed who has changed maybe even why
they change it and we can also validate
different infrastructure changes as we
do with application code in pipeline
before deployment on production we can
deploy the same change in test
environment see how it behaves and so on
so terraform who know what is terraform
or who use terraform like okay so less
than half of people raise hand some
people raise hand under the desk which
still count so i guess many of you know
what is terraformed okay so terraform in
nutshell started in 2014 as a tool to
create update and change infrastructure
safely and in predictable way so that we
always know what's going to change we
don't want to have different surprises
so this is how a typical configuration
file in terraform looks like I'm talking
about
0:11 which was created for quite some
time
0:12 was released three weeks ago there
is very little difference but I will
highlight them during talk as well so
this is how a configuration file looks
like it is text file where we specify
variable which we want to use and we
specify what kind of resource we want to
make and then we run several commands to
download dependencies terraform in it
will download dependencies required to
talk to different cloud providers like
in this case a table years and then I
run a terraform apply in order to see
what's going to happen so in this case I
want to create bucket with random name
so that's what it tell I confirm this
was yes that that's exactly what I want
and then after six seconds my bucket
called my bucket see snail is created
that's all what we have so we create
text file we declare what we want and we
run tariffs on Commons to get these
resources created you may think that AWS
has CloudFormation Google has Google
Cloud deployment manager nature of
course said that there is nothing else
better than Jason so here is a sure
resource manager and why these providers
create this they wanted to let users to
manage the infrastructure on that
provider so there is almost no way no
easy way to combine resources between
these providers and then terraform
appeared and say ok no problem we have
more than hundred more providers in
addition to these three so that's that's
pretty good right so you may think that
ok we have support for all of these
providers which we can easily combine
and declare in the same syntax so we are
using the same language we don't have to
mix Python for Google Cloud and llamó
or JSON for CloudFormation or a sure
resource panel we all define in language
which is called HCl which is short form
for hajeck or configuration language
so that's really good that we don't need
to know all of this and try to come up
with all of these things but in addition
to this terraform was designed to be
used to be reused so there are lots of
different concepts in terraform built-in
which allows us to write small amount of
code and reuse it across different
projects different solutions so that's
that's really a differentiator and back
in 2014 for those who don't remember
what was the time all of those tools
like CloudFormation as your google
deployment manager you just execute your
script you fingers crossed and we hope
that nothing is destroyed okay that's
this mod is called finger crossed wes
terraform this was taken very seriously
and there are concepts like terraform
state file where we know that there is
known known collection of our known
specification known description of
resources which we already managed with
stirrup form so we can always compare
what's going to happen and we don't have
to turn on fingers cross mode every time
we see what's going to happen we
confirmed that this is exactly what we
want and we apply this change back in
2014 it was one of the best benefit
which you can tell to anybody and they
will say oh my god I'm going to use
terraform immediately I remember this
time myself when I showed it to some of
my customer and they say like oh my god
I abandon CloudFormation from right now
and yeah since they're happy users of
terraform so terraform is actually a
universal tool as long as there is an
api it means that there is a way to
instruct terraform to manage resources
on any other providers for example if
you want to order a pizza I mean yes
Domino has an API so you just specify
size of pizza what kind of stuff to put
you specify your credit card details and
then API call will be made by terraform
to Domino pizza and eventually your
pizza will be delivered
it's nice I think right I mean isn't it
what's our form for actually a Minecraft
is what is it for
I mean minecraft also has an API so in
Minecraft you can specify in position
what type of object you want to place on
XYZ coordinates and you can also specify
dependencies that you can say first
built this plate and then put sheep on
top of it so there will be specific
telephone will handle dependencies in
order to figure out in which sequence to
build these objects again this is an
example of API more traditional of
course it's public cloud like AWS which
takes I guess about 70% of all attention
to terraform and many other providers
like community developed by for example
Dropbox or to manage your Google
applications or Gmail accounts you can
create issues with terraform and so on
so many different providers exist right
now I think there are about 170 or about
190 different providers by community so
let's start with something more real ok
because not everybody is playing
minecraft not everybody ordering pizza
on Domino though I order it okay so
let's manage AWS Network stack this is
getting to be a little bit more advanced
and maybe Oh actually I forgot to
mention this is going to be advanced
talk ok it's not going to be about
ordering pizza and minecraft anymore so
let's deep dive into some more terraform
specifics so this is how we want to
create VPC we specify cedar block and we
run tariffs on Commons and then we'll
get cedar blocks allocated for this VPC
then we extend this this text file and
we want to have internet access so we
specify that now we want to add Internet
gateway and we tell for which we PC
that's easy then we add subnets ok
because obviously we need to put some
resources so we specify a couple more
resources and then we
going to add some more resources like
routing table route table Association
rules not gateways elastic IP address
and so on so for very small and for a
pretty pretty simple Network stack on
almost any project this network
configuration file will contain two to
three hundred lines easily so it's it's
not a lot but it's not something what is
a differentiator for your business most
likely so there will be a lot of files
and a lot of lines sorry and as we can
see the amount of code is always
increasing and the complexity is going
to be increasing as well so VPC Internet
gateway subnets all of them are
dependent to each other and it will be
pretty tricky to manage this so the
first thing which terraform came up out
of the box back in long long time ago
was there are four modules so terraform
models are just self-contained packages
of terraform file which we always call
as a single unit so that's the only
thing which you need to know about there
are four modules when you think about
them so there are two types of modules
one is called resource modules in
particular those which I maintain under
terraform alias modules github account
and there are another type of module
which is called infrastructure modules
so let's look into more details about
first group resource modules are are
designed to be extremely flexible and
they handle all of the complexity inside
of it and they are not containing any
business logic they don't have any
opinions they just let you do whatever
is possible with this resource so
they're great candidate to be open
source and majority of modules which you
find in open source I mean in the public
they are exactly the resource modules so
resource modules in terraform can be
involved like this first we specify from
which place we'll want to call it in
this case we specify that we want to use
HTTP sub module from security group
module we specify which version we want
to
yet and we specify different attributes
or arguments which we want to pass to
that module so that's easy in this case
we are calling module and we want to
open to have security group with just
HTTP ports open
so first question to people especially
for those who use tariffs one so would
you use tariffs for module to manage AWS
ec2 security group or would you just
write resource in to resources like
security group and the touch bunch of
different rules to it so the question is
would you use tariffs or module to
manage AWS ec2 security group nobody
raising hands means that nobody would
use it right okay that's good watch this
movie
and so on so this is a real logic which
you will have to implement if you want
to create security group yourself on AWS
there are about 600 or 800 lines in
order to create security group in really
flexible configuration when I say
flexible then it means that you as user
of AWS you seldomly think about what is
actually inside of terraform AWS
provider AWS SDK AWS internals you are
abstracted away from all of this and
that's the purpose of resource modules
is that you don't have to know internal
implementation of how to create ipv6
rules ipv4 prefix list self references
all protocols name group and and
something else all of this is handled by
these resource modules which you don't
have to know and you don't have to make
this yourself in order to use it so the
abstraction here is a key that you don't
have to know all of details in order to
use it so think about this as a benefit
of resource modules in first place and
second type of module is infrastructure
module which is obviously consisting of
some resource modules because you don't
want to deal with internals and this is
often the place for your company to
implement all standards which you have
in company like namings security
encryption and other things which are
relevant for your industry or for your
company specifically and back in 2015 or
and 217 or actually up until now it is
the only place where you can use
different kind of processors like JSON
net cookie cutter to generate code for
your module and let other people in the
organization to use it the invocation of
infrastructure module is very similar we
specify where we wanted to get and then
we specify different arguments which we
want to pass inside of the module
we can see that we are just involved in
different versions of different modules
so we say that we want to make V PC by
invoking this module and application law
dancer and so on so it's no different
there is no big difference between
resource and infrastructure module so
let's talk about what to do and what not
to do with there are four modules one of
the frequent problem is that when you
start writing module you are trying to
solve just your use case and if you are
working alone in entire isolation you
will never care about anyone else
but it's unlikely and most likely you
have some other team some other
colleague somebody else who wants or who
should not reinvent the same solution
which you came up with so that's
important point to write code which
other people can use even in the
organization so the first evil part in
modules which I see quite often is that
people food provider blocks and they
assume that everybody will be using this
module just in this configuration this
is pretty bad idea because it's not
possible to inherit and all right
provider blocks so easily with terraform
so never put this inside of your module
itself always think about this as layer
and put providers configuration as high
as possible way it makes sense so second
evil part is provisionary provision is
something what allows you to execute
different shell script or CLI like AWS
CLI after resource has been created in
this case you know we are totally we are
tightly coupling AWS VPC resource
together with provision which is pretty
bad idea it is bad because it's not
possible to extend or override this
resource at all so just try to not put
this resource this section at all in
your files and always use something
outside of terraform which is
and simple puppet or whatever else what
you can trigger after that after
resource is created and even if you
think that okay there is an instance and
I will launch this instance and then I
want to run ansible playbook from my
local machine and connect to this
instance and do whatever I want it is
often better here because it's not
possible to extend what is actually the
problem part and provision are here in
instance which many people don't think
about is it at some point you will think
about now I want to make launch
configuration and I want to auto scale
my instance even if I want to have
minimum maximum desired capacity to one
the thing is that it's not possible to
use provisioners on launch
configurations so the solution here is
as you use user data and only when
instance is launched then the common
pattern is that you actually download
playbooks from s3 and you execute them
on machine locally once instances up and
running so this is a common problem
which many people don't realize unless
they they are told to implement auto
scaling group so at some point you may
think that okay I actually need to
extend functionality of certain
resources which are available in AWS SDK
or AWS CLI so I really want to use my
local machine so new resource is special
type of resource which is not actually
like resource because it's new resource
but it is possible to say that once vbc
is created then actually run this
commons which I want so this way it is
possible to have vbc creation and
execution of AWS CLI independently and
there are many different points which I
highlighted and I think they are pretty
relevant if you want to write code in
terraform which is actually useful and I
order them these points
i buy this order because I believe that
documentation and example is the most
important part not test because I mean
tests are useless because simply a first
you have to know what this module is
doing how to use it what to expect from
it okay does it have enough features
which I need right now
what kind of defaults does it have is it
opinionated and everything is hard-coded
hopefully not
does it create just resources which I
want or it also creates sums in what I
really don't need so this means clean
code and then at the end yes you may
have some automation regarding regarding
this module where you can run example
you can verify that output of this was
as expected and this is a pretty hot
area where everybody thinks that they
need tests I don't believe that people
need tests unless they implement at
least four steps before that so if you
disagree I would really like to talk to
you about Tara grant aw a spec in spec
show respect and any other tool which
you know about this because I kind of
put it in this order and I'd like to
know what you think about it so are
there are four modules enough
unfortunately not because it is good
start but it's not enough
okay so let's look into how to structure
telephone configurations and we will see
more about more about how to call them
so if we look into how our project
evolved first we started with small main
TF file we put in two different files
then we figure out that okay we we are
doing something what is not actually
differentiating so we go to place where
other people publish their modules and
we find something there and we start
using it okay so now we we found VPC
module auto scaling group RDS so we have
our own mess okay we will soon have mess
now it's time to think about okay how to
actually orchestrate this how
- maybe separate this so let's look into
different patterns here
the first way which is probably on the
very left side is called all-in-one is
where we just invoke in all of these
modules one by one so we specify all of
these modules after modules and it it
eventually gets bigger and bigger and if
next time when we're on terraform apply
it will take 10 minutes 15 minutes and
then we'll think like yeah it doesn't
look so good so maybe it's arrow form is
bad maybe I have to move to something
else this is what people think
no in fact you start with something what
you probably have to evolve and second
way on the very far right is one in one
is well we have very small blast radius
where we are just invoking a single
module or small collection of modules
and we specify that if I'm working on V
PC then I will not be able to affect
anything else than just V PC so i go to
V PC folder I work in that isolation and
that's it there is very small blast
radius that's important point and let's
think about especially those who use the
reform already which way do you group
your code at work like all in one or one
and one so all in one is on one side and
one on one is an on this side who is
thinking that all in one is what you
have and what you probably like anyone
right but actually there are people but
you're just shy okay but one in one who
think that this is good and this is what
we should be using right okay so yeah
it's quite obvious that people think
that yeah one in one's good and I
definitely have to use it and the
correct things are actually MFA is it's
somewhere in between is true okay
because most frequently or at least what
I'm speaking about myself is when I wake
up and I think like oh that's going to
be an awesome project I will make
everything perfect from day one no
shortcuts everything will
be ready in time believe me it's not
happening like this okay I always start
with one file I put a bunch of different
things I experiment there I connect
different components especially in
situations which I never worked with
before it will be much faster for me to
work in a big snowball of mass and try
to connect different resources before I
figure out different patterns and can
extrapolate it one in one on another
side is when I clearly know that this is
a well-established project it's not the
one of the project I already know that
okay we have some application we have
some load balancers we have some VPC and
what is really important is that if I'm
not working on this alone which means
that there will be different type of
people involved it's really beneficial
to think about 1 + 1 or somewhere in
that area if I have created some code
before for example to set up similar
infrastructure 1 + 1 is very nature of
choice for me so normally 1 + 1 is
something what people are aiming for but
they're always starting with all in one
I mean occasionally people start
thinking about like pre optimization and
trying to make everything perfect but
then they you know what's happening with
optimization in advance right it will
kill the project so what about terraform
workspaces who think that terraform
workspaces is awesome ok for those who
don't know what is telephone workspaces
let me tell that this is not awesome ok
telephone workspaces is not awesome
telephone workspaces was designed by
Hershey Corp it became part of terraform
because because why not I mean people
have one folder and they want to execute
the same code for for similar situation
with slightly different variables so for
example I have project a and I want to
have a very similar project but for
project B which is very similar but just
a little bit difference I honestly
believe and I'm glad that many many
people
my vision is that terraform workspaces
is the evil there are two evil parts in
terraform which I really like to
highlight because I understand what I'm
talking about there are four workspaces
and provisionary these two things which
should never be used in any real
projects so never ever use them
the problem with workspace is that we
are not paying for disk storage we are
paying for code readability
so always copy paste code use some
abstractions use something what is very
easy for human to understand we are not
writing code for computers anymore right
we are not paying for two kilobytes
saved of on my disk so always try to
write something of what human will
understand and documentation says what
is Tara for workspaces in much more
details so if you will read this
documentation you may have some idea
that oh yeah that's actually what I need
but please read it carefully and don't
try to to use it unless you have a lot
of money okay it's paid fission so
solution again we already know what is
module so why not use the same module
but just provide different arguments to
it so that's easy again we are not
paying for storage we are paying for
support of this code so terraform 0:12
has been released three weeks ago if
you've been following this process for
quite some time
terraform 0:12 was announced
approximately a year ago and a lot of
people will expect and that it is going
to be solving my all of my needs it was
all of my code because of all of cool
features it has simplified syntax where
we don't have to write double quotes
dollar Carelli brackets anymore
isn't it nice we can have loops we can
have dynamics blocks we can have correct
conditional iterations where left and
right parts are executed not
simultaneously we can have extended
types like
list of maps of strings of maps of lists
of strings
isn't it beautiful that we can have
instead of just integer string and
boolean we can have so nice complicated
stuff we can have templates and values
which is I don't even have example why
you would need it but a lot of a lot of
cool stuff was announced and I have
filled and I believe myself is that it's
going to be pretty solid change to many
many projects many companies were there
where they were using terraform 0 11 and
what I want to to talk about is that not
everything will be alright okay because
there are very important point in
terraform users community we have to
think about different types of users and
when I say that different types of users
I'm not saying that this is good and
this is bad I'm just saying that we
cannot like to put it another way who
know where has full-stack developers
right I mean probably everyone so you
know that previously we had front-end
back-end let's combine them then what
else what kind of skills we should
inflate into full stack developers in
order for them to be still full stack
developer should they also know
terraform hopefully not so there are
terraform developers who are familiar
with how to write terraform modules how
to use different features of telephone
how to use your public cloud of choice
how to implement company standards and
they know these standards and they can
implement them they can maintain
reference architecture for your company
so that they really know ok we are
dealing with micro services this is how
we deploy our micro service this is how
we manage different resources related to
micro service and they can make
reference architecture for everybody to
look into and to discuss
while on another side there are 90% of
people who just want to get things done
and that's really important to
understand is that we cannot always
expect people let's say front-end
developers - hey please write awesome
terraform code he will be able to do
this and I'm not saying that front-end
developers is bad by definition to work
with terraform but I just don't want to
to make HR process even more harder now
that they have to look for full-stack
developers with terraform skills I
simply don't know anyone here in Oslo I
live in Oslo so it's it's just bad - to
require everybody know terraform and be
domain expert no JavaScript nope it--and
no these know that on very high level so
what I'm saying is that era forum users
are those who can figure out which
component they want to change or they go
to reference architecture and they
figure out okay this is how we deal with
micro stories so they call this service
without deep understanding of how and
why it was implemented this way and they
just specified correct values there so
they tell ok this is my key value or
whatever type of input this model accept
and that's it that's where they are the
main experts they know what type of
stuff this module accept and they
provide it the complexity is treated by
terraform developers who actually wrote
these modules so for telephone
developers terraform 0:12
has actually enormous amount of features
so all of these features which were
listed here that's exactly what
terraform developers who developed
modules were looking for so yes we need
loops we need dynamic blocks we need all
of these features in order to implement
and handle the resource creation the way
we want so I honestly was not able to
write modules for some very easy
resources which you may think like why
why not
for example s3 bucket in terraform 0:11
I couldn't make it with less
six out 6,000 lines in terraform zero
twelve it's 100 lines so it's it's big
different but the code which if you look
into that you will think that this is
crazy
and that something what I don't want
users to to deal with so terraform zero
twelve for users bring only one thing it
is that they actually see much easy
syntax so if they have to change
something it will be much easier for
them to to handle it
they don't have to know crazy amount of
interpolation functions and escaping and
so on it's much more simplified so
that's the only benefit for them as a
summary I want to say that yes in fact
terraform modules they are definitely
must-have and as a as I said we cannot
start with everything perfect but we
still have to reach to that we have to
go to the direction where 1 in 1 plus
Tara grant is something what we should
be aiming Tara grant is a third-party
tool which allows to orchestrate
invocation of infrastructure modules so
think about this as something what you
can call and it will handle dependencies
for you so for example dependency can be
that instance can be launched only after
network is created so you go to the
folder and you're on Tara grant apply
and then it goes through dependencies
and figure out which one has to be
created first and then it creates it
while having one in one structure it's
very convenient and very easy to explain
to people who are not professional
terraform developers and if you don't
have lots of money but you think that
terraform workspace is for you please
copy paste files it's much much easier
and terraform 0:12 is awesome but
unfortunately it's or not unfortunately
realistically it's awesome for
developers not for users so for me this
means that I will be able
right even more modules maintain them in
much easier way for example I will be
able to create cloud front modules as
three modules Canisius modules and
elasticsearch this means that if you
need to setup your infrastructure you
again don't have to be an expert in
terraform in AWS in terraform a SS
providers in terraform limitations you
just specify that you need elasticsearch
of this size in this availability zone
that's it the rest heavy liftin which is
creation of like five to ten different
resources is happening without without
you understanding it you it's always
open source and you can always
contribute and you can always use this
code the way you want you can fork it
you can make your changes but at least
it's it's very easy way to get started
and yeah I think that's all for me I was
told that there is box somewhere where
you have to put something but as a hint
I don't know why but green piece of
paper is much bigger I don't know why so
thanks for that and if you have any
questions I will be here today and
tomorrow and you can ask me anything on
Twitter and github I have some stickers
actually as well if you are into that
like this module cf is one of my project
where you get visual diagrams created in
cloud crafts you click export and you
get a reformed configuration generated
from these visual diagrams it is open
source and I have stickers and if you
want to add some new features edit into
cloud craft or two modules TF or to any
projects just let me know cool yeah
thank you
you have question yeah so the question
was how how what is the difference
between community terraform
CloudFormation and Google and so on the
community in terraform is built I mean
where community is like what's the
purpose of community that's all is to
share knowledge and to get your problem
fixed as far as I know Google as well as
CloudFormation does not have anything
like registry so there is no single
place where you can go and you can say
Oh what is the best way to set up let's
say network in Google literally I have
no clue where to go I can go to
documentation I can ask in different
slack channels I can ask different
people and so on and I will get 20
different results 20 different solutions
what is difference between hajeck or
communities is that yes of course there
are different slack channels mailing
lists community dashi curve dot-com but
all of these discussions are around
something what people share in central
place which is registry dot terraform
dot IO there are about about a thousand
of modules contributed by people and you
can just see the contribution and you
can easily find something to talk about
there are many different good
communities like slack
I can recommend Han Han gobs is one I
think there are more than thousands of
terraform developers right now and
another one is sweet ops sweet ops yeah
we started it pretty a long time ago but
we have about 30 people joining every
every week yeah every week so we are
almost reaching 1,000 of people and work
which we have there is primarily support
so if you have any question about staff
which we develop
you go there to specific room and you
ask question and most likely there will
be people answering you what I
personally don't like with many of these
communities is that you ask questions
and nobody answering right I mean we've
been to this position many times I'm
asked constantly different questions
which I try to answer but if it takes me
more than a couple hours a day then I
try to to kind of get paid for that but
yeah any other questions please let me
know we have one minute yeah that's a
really good question so I will repeat
question there will there are actually a
lot of tools similar to terraform which
allows to to do similar things I mean I
use word similar because it's really
similar it's not exactly the same it's
similar okay
and yes you're absolutely right there
are they will be talked by Paul stack
somewhere I think later today about but
I don't know actually what he was going
to talk about but he is a guy who
developed a terraform in about 2016 and
then he moved to another company who is
developing a competitor of terraform so
I really encourage you to check his talk
although I'm not sure if he will be
talking about that one in any case where
terraform shine is creation of
infrastructure it's not going to replace
your puppet unstable because it's not
configuration management it's not going
to go deep into each of resource which
you create and configure them so it's
not going to replace things like Packer
or vagrant which we use to create
immutable images as well as it's not
going to replace Tokyo communities
it's just something were crates in
structure infrastructure is needed for
other things to be working on like your
services cannot run without network so
someone has to set up network and this
is where historically all of these tools
were able to jump in and say hey we can
fix Network like with ansible you can do
everything right
you can set up literally the same amount
of resources the benefit of telephone
though is that it's very declarative you
are not specifying to this after this
after this though I know some companies
who have invented or invented in quotes
of course made terraform using ansible
so think about this is that they solve
problems like dependencies and that
instances has to be created after
network is created using ansible what is
it notifications or how it's called an
instable hooks notifications so it
looked like big monster of course that
it is possible as well as similar
projects people do with puppet I mean
puppet can create different resources so
that's way to go know it's in fact it's
not because code is not designed for
that terraform has very clear separation
is that there is telephone core there is
terraform provider and there is your
terraform module which manage telephone
resources so you have this very clear
separation between this while puppet is
more like big monster with some modules
which some resources so it doesn't have
very clear separation so yeah that's
that's the biggest difference when it
comes to Google I simply don't know any
place where I can just go and get list
of like preferred ways to set up
networking I mean of course I can read
the commentation I can do the heavy lift
and I can understand how networks
supposed to be built in Google read
bunch of different best practices come
up with my solution but the idea of at
least my understanding the idea of
DevOps and business is that you actually
focus on what you supposed to be doing
you don't have to know everything in
order to sell your stuff on your website
and that's not what gonna to to help you
with so don't don't try to come up with
solution unless it's really important
for your business and network is
unlikely the main business for most of
you guys yeah any other questions no but
I have stickers right okay thanks a lot